hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play amnesia custom story
abduction
wow that was a longest intro ever okay
ah-oh
dead dead guy nice ass dead guy I'm
sorry I'm taken not really but I'm not
so lonely okay three days now
three number three fear hers uh
no coding here on the prey the mass per
turn we all may perish Oh sounds like
Helens a bad person he's going crazy oh
please tell me Alexander's gonna get
killed by Helen oh you go girl
get him oh why am i all sit ah what the
hell happened just from that dead guy
really that's what that's that's what
did you over Daniel such a coward get me
all Oh gonna gonna stab Alexander so
hard all right
whew this is a very very involved custom
story I mean there's a lot of stuff
honestly very good ah I don't trust you
get out of here get out of here do not
like those guys I do not like them at
all come here
um okay this door
hello hello a picture Alexander oh it's
so nice why have you not returned to me
your has passed and your loneliness as
is all the wine please love come back to
me haha Alexander oh no it was that from
Helen probably cuz you know Alexander
Alexander wouldn't have a picture of
himself right there and there he's not
that conceited well actually he is but
whatever where's this go library you
darn it of course I do
Missy um storage oh I hate storages
storage is how this all started food
storage no it's a bad storage give me
some light why I got 38 tinderboxes
jeebus goodness gravy that is really
dark in here he's like you're doing
nothing or these torches just suck that
seems more likely
den the box yes give me your tinderbox
Oh another one
gimme give me what's this this is piece
of wood what am i kleptomania umm I
don't see anything else
brooches again
ooh why is it so why is there sunlight
and yet it still so dark makes no sense
pieces of metal mushrooms um nothing
nothing nothing
are you is that it a little kid
oh so strong get oil give me up
tinderbox can't get away from me yeah oh
yeah oh you shut up there we go alright
ah I did [ __ ] uh uh-huh I don't even
know my own strength
let's ripped it apart go ah ha monster
that's a monster that's a monster that's
the buzzer is about to miss you butcher
Hey Oh get out of here Oh get out of
here
Oh get out of here guy Oh get out of
here I can't see a thing
oh good man all those boxes just
exploded ah you almost gave me a heart
attack what are you trying to do kill me
huh ha ha ha ha I made a joke ok
where is he where is he where is he
going
what is he doing she's gonna come up
here it's gonna be right around the
corner come on guy get out of here no
one likes you
okay I think he's moved on
maybe okay
okay that's definitely some sort of
screaming in the background
huh man okay I'm better I'm okay I'm
okay guys don't worry about me I'm so
tough um habit to do even if it didn't
do to do nothing nothing Nathan behind
the barrels there's mushrooms okay all
right yeah yeah you give me so many
torches but they don't do jack doodlee
hey Sonoma oil actually no I'm being
very good about right about this open
open sesame oil more oil yeah thank you
up there okay well looks like I came in
here for nothing just had a net loss of
one tinderbox
um yeah nothing um nothing okay moving
on oh good Oh
Oh moose man I get it out of here moose
man you can't find me oh so great oh I'm
so great look at me
oh he sounds like um President Nixon
from Futurama Haru I know not in this
door why you're in this doorway in this
one why why in this one why okay down
here can we get out of your mousse man
move man move man oh oh oh good honey
don't make a loop don't make a loop
don't make a loop do not loop oh [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you doo-doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo gimme what did I come in
here for like why did I come here go
ahead come here why not come here ah
please man I don't like you
oh I'm dying give me some laudanum
uh oh gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme
oh boy okay I'm okay
boy he's boss my box get away box down
my way box oh I don't have time for you
oh lawd anonym thank you thank you for
this wonderful bounty oh okay okay
Bora Tori again oh man that's a long way
to the laboratory this is a big big
custom story big custom story oh man ah
get out of here oh I don't wanna oh I'm
gonna have so much oil oh boy
okay I'm okay I'm okay
Oh tinderboxes huh ah no what the hell
get out of here
stop following me you're very you're
very creepy you're very creepy oh man oh
there are kids screaming in the
background always that just a fake-out
who is this a fake-out oh man no one
likes you moves man oh yes another prize
under the stuck it open now the prize
under this to get open
girl but ah I'm gonna kill you I hate
you oh you you you you you you you you
you you you gotcha [ __ ] yeah oh yeah
okay hopefully the moose man has vacated
the premises how did I miss something in
here oh man oh yes tinderboxes oh okay
oh wow herb a doobie
my hands are tingling oh man
okay need to find a key to the
laboratory and then do something in the
laboratory at best did I go in here yeah
I did yeah did I go in here baby
this is nothing
oh yeah I missed a missus huh
Oh rabbit get out of here dog head lit
if this is a whole nother world it seems
a lot you know the same ish - ma Daniels
or I'm not even sure if Daniels the
world is my world I don't know okay
alright guest room Wow bad stuff
happened the guest from before I'm gonna
cut it here thank you guys so much for
watching I'm gonna take a breather so I
can catch my breath but thank you so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next part
bye bye